i don't think they really want to go
where they're trying to take us either
if they really think about it you know i
hope they will read saving nine
because regardless of whether they agree
with me on any other policy issue they
ought to be able to agree that the
minute you rip off that band-aid and for
reasons i explain in the book the minute
you
start to politicize the court formally
as you would do by increasing the number
of justices in order to achieve a
desired political outcome
there is no stopping it
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the senior senator from the great state
of utah and the author of the new book
saving nine the fight against the left's
audacious plan to pack the supreme court
and destroy american liberty senator
mike lee finally welcome to the reuben
report
thank you very much it's good to be with
you
well you have handed me an awful lot
that i'm talking an awful lot about in
the title
of the new book and i want to focus an
awful lot on that but first what is it
like to be on the short list of what i
would call
uh sane people in the united states
government right now yeah it's sort of
like
being one of the tallest buildings in
tooele utah you might say there are a
lot of tall buildings here i take it
short buildings over there yeah yeah i
mean what is going on
yeah so what is going on right now with
the government and just the amount of
people that seemingly are doing nothing
or all of the wrong things yeah
the the problem is less about doing
nothing and more about doing all the
wrong things when people start to think
that god is government and when they
start to think that all government needs
to take place and transpire in
washington dc that's a wicked
combination the combination we've been
living under for many decades but it's
reached a boiling point of late and the
left wants to make it a lot worse we're
here to stop it
so that really is in many ways what the
book is about and one of the things that
you talk about and i've been trying to
hit on for a while on the show i i have
tried and i generally try not to impugn
people's motives but as you know the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions and
it seems to me at this point what we are
seeing out of the left and virtually the
entire democrat party is in an
intentional destruction of so many of
the things that the founders uh had
built and and had created to allow us to
all live free so before we get into the
specifics what do you think about the
intentions part do you think a lot of
what's going on is intentional or do you
think it's confusion or a
misunderstanding of the documents or
something else altogether
you know i tend to believe that most
people on the left
have at least convinced themselves that
the place they want to take us is a good
place that that would be good for the
country in the case of uh packing the
supreme court for example i i think they
somehow believe
that that would take us to a better
place now i i wrote saving nine in order
to explain why the opposite is true so
but regardless of what their intention
is i have no ability to jump into
someone else's mind to read their mind
to know the the inner
thoughts and intentions of their heart
and their soul and their mind but what i
do know is
certain things that history tells us and
history tells us that there are some
mistakes we ought not want to repeat as
mitch mcconnell likes to say there's no
education in the second kick from the
mule we've already been kicked by the
court packing mule once i described that
at great length in chapter four of
saving nine we do not want the education
that would come from the second kick of
that same mule so when you hear your
colleagues across the aisle talking
about packing the court and you're
hearing it all the time now i mean it's
virtually every day someone is saying it
do you ever try to pull them aside and
say hey do you guys realize that if you
pack the court this time we'll just pack
the court next time or that perhaps this
is a complete affront to the separation
of powers or a series of other things
that you get into in the book but you
kind of say them hey do you realize what
you're going to do here even if you
temporarily get what you want of course
of course and you know for the time
being uh they're they're content with
talking about it but not really doing it
at least not yet i think they're waiting
to do that perhaps until the dobbs
ruling is actually issued and maybe
that's when they start through it in
earnest then it gets very very serious
but i think you're right to point that
out i don't think they really want to go
where they're trying to take us either
if they really think about it you know i
hope they will read saving nine
because regardless of whether they agree
with me on any other policy issue they
ought to be able to agree that the
minute you rip off that band-aid and for
reasons i explain in the book the minute
you
start
to politicize the court formally as you
would do by increasing the number of
justices in order to achieve a desired
political outcome
there is no stopping it
the republicans who in modern history
have never attempted anything like this
would be compelled
to do the same thing the next time the
shoe is on the other foot that is the
next time the house and the senate and
the white house are all under the
control of the same party if the
democrats increase by four you can see
republicans increasing up by four more
maybe it will be six next time
the result of that won't be pleasant for
anyone the court because of the lifetime
appointment guarantee of article 3 of
the constitution
this will be a one-way ratchet
and the the court will expand a lot
faster than it could ever shrink before
long it won't look like a court at all
but like a political body and a large
one at that
eventually it looked like the
intergalactic senate in the star wars
movie series
believe it or not i am a big fan of the
prequels and i think that they're
looking better and better over time
because of exactly that you know how
power just flips depending on who's in
charge um at what point do you think
that packing the court
is actually an assault on the
constitution itself in in other words
that one branch of government would in
essence be destroying another branch of
government they're supposed to have
checks and balances but to me that's a
it's it's almost a violation of the oath
of office if you if your goal as a
legislator is to override what the
judiciary is supposed to be comprised of
yeah no that's exactly right and i think
if you're doing it the minute you're
doing it not because the court is short
staffed i think in theory that could be
a legitimate reason to do it if it's
some unknown point in the future uh
there's widespread consensus that
they're uh the the human resources on
the court uh have been outpaced by the
caseload
you could consider an argument then even
then you would want to be very careful
about phasing in the increases
but whereas here they're just talking
about a political outcome that they
desire they want to achieve then this is
an assault on that here's the
interesting thing about that
it's kind of an irony built into it
packing the supreme court isn't
unconstitutional
congress does have that power
but packing it with this intention in
mind under this circumstance
really is anti-constitutional it would
undermine the separation of powers
not not as a bug but as a feature and
that's what makes it so wrong
but do you think it matters to them you
know what i mean like they sort of their
their ends justify the means so do you
think it really matters meaning that if
they can go ahead and do it and get away
with it which seemingly you can get away
with virtually anything these days then
why not go ahead and do it i know that's
not your position but from their
perspective from their perspective that
often is a big motivator and i think
that is part of why they're doing it
notwithstanding some of these risks uh
is that they're looking at this saying
if we can do it
and it would please our base
why not do it uh why not at least try
maybe we will swing and miss but we'll
at least draw a lot of great applause
from our own base
but for the reasons i explained in
chapter four of saving nine
even when you
swing and miss even when you threaten to
pack the court you propose court packing
and the legislation fails it can leave
an indelible mark a mark that we're
still paying for uh in the uh you know
lengthy period of time it's elapsed
since 1937 when they tried it last we're
still suffering from what happened to
the court what it did to the court
all
that many years ago 85 years later and
we're still paying for that mistake if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell